joe rogan had coveted
and he took uh ivermectin
his methods included taking ivermectin a
deworming veterinary drug
if you believe in veterinary
that is formulated for using cows and
horses
um
[Music]
while a version of the drug is sometime
prescribed to people for head lice or
skin condition
now look i have had i've had head lice i
probably had head lice
i would say 13 times maybe 14 times
maybe 13 maybe a baker's dozen all right
dude i'm upstair you upstairs when you
have headlights dude you're upstairs all
day
you're itching the top floor dog you
know
so
um
[Music]
so yeah i noticed a lot of articles
people trashing what does he do you know
this guy what is an idiot you know he's
taking these taking this
why would he do you know
dude
i've always found i i think it's brave
to try something
whatever happened to that thing hey
maybe this guy found it
maybe this guy this worked for him
i don't think he's out there saying it's
going to work for everybody
um
but also the people writing a lot of
articles trashing him about it
dude he's such he he's such your daddy
he's your daddy because you're only
writing that article to get the links to
get the links to get the um
people to link on it so you can get your
money get you a little 50 70
and that's
daddy joe
making you money boy keeping you're in
business
he's out there trying different things
and joe rogan's not gonna try something
that's dumb
have you seen joe rogan
if there's if there's if there's there's
many things he cares about one of them
is his physical health
dude ivor the first time i ever uh even
met him he was coming out of a damn
a portal
he'd been in i swear to god he'd been in
some type of portal to another sphere
something where
you know they put alien uh
fat in your limbs or something i don't
know i mean just the guy's always trying
something new
um
so i think this is brave i think it's
brave of him to try it and especially if
it worked for him he got it for a couple
days he got sick
and uh and he got better i think he beat
it in three days
and that sound look
this is one of the
and this isn't me uh pat and joe rogan
on the back
you know
he's not my daddy
um
he's my uncle i think
you know uncle joey's my uncle
uh uncle joe uncle tom
segura
um not the
whatever the other guy did that i think
was kind of he's somebody did something
bad but um
uncle burt uncle uh
uh
[Music]
sebastian
i mean those guys are guys that i would
go to for suggestions i know if i needed
some help
uh
they would reply uncle jocko you know
different guys
uncle poirier
but joe rogan's a smart guy that cares
about his health
so i just don't i don't think like
oh and it says what does it say the fda
is urging people to stop taking the drug
to fight covet 19.
um
but my thing about the fda is and look
i'm an idiot
okay
i'm just thinking out loud
but is the fda compromised that's what i
worry a lot about the fda
because i bought some of their meat
you know
and it's good but it's not all
it's not all 90 lean that's for sure
and is the fda compromised dude
everything's compromised i remember our
school board was compromised growing up
do we had to drink bad milk for a year
we were drinking sour milk because the
guy there was banging the um
[Music]
the
uh what was that milk company buzz
called
uh
yeah the guy was banging the board one
of the boarding chicks the
superintendent or whatever
so we're out there dude every day at
lunch just sipping man
this was on the cusp bro i'll tell
you this if you got that at about
it was still digestible if you got that
little milk bag that lunch bag about 11
40.
that just it tasted like you were
it tasted like i had a little pickle
back shot at the at the bottom of the
bag baby
so
so i just wonder how compromised is it
and i'm kind of a skeptic i am skeptical
you know
i am skeptical of a uh
of an of of of everything these days a
lot of things are compromised
that's money man that's big business
so
i don't know man but i think the fact
that
if joe rogan tries it
he's a brave dude he's tries out he's
tried a lot of things that have
helped a lot of people
you know he really is kind of the
he's a guinea pig
in a lot of ways and
um
and
i think that's brave
you know he encourages me to want to try
different things to see if they work for
me
now this could be risky i don't know
everything i'm not telling people to go
try ivermectin i don't know that much
about it
but
there's been a lot of people who have
said uh there's been a lot of talk about
it helping people so
uh i don't know i think he's brave
enough to do it i would like to see that
article more hey here's a guy who's
brave enough who's got a lot to write i
mean he's got a wonderful life
you know he's got a comfortable neat
life where he's
doing it you know he's doing interesting
things all the time but his health he
cares about it i know he does
the first time i met him he was coming
out of a medical clinic in the elevator
and i was just like
you know i just met him he was getting
he's doing something doing stem cells
you've got some new stem cell bubble gum
or something
you know i mean he's always
so anyway i think it's brave man i think
it's interesting and brave and maybe
i'll get to talk to him about it
firsthand one day um
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one